bonsoir michel tonini merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour commenter ce
lancement en direct dans quatre minutes
cinquante et une secondes exactement
comment se préparent les derniers
instants et spationautes sont à bord oui
bonsoir les astronautes à bord ils sont
montés à bord avec une procédure qui
ressemble beaucoup à celle qu on utilise
lorsqu'on rentre dans un vaisseau russe
soyouz sur une année spatiale c'est
environ deux heures et demie avant le
décollage et on fait les diriger
cassions interne des systèmes et de
pressurisation du vaisseau avant le
décollage
alors le président américain est arrivée
à 20h38 exactement c'est important pour
lui ce sont des enjeux importants pour
les américains c'est quand même un grand
pays d'asie qui ont été des précurseurs
pour l'envoi des êtres humains dans
l'espace de même que les que l'urss et
donc ils ont arrêté les vols sur l'année
spatiale en lui environ 8 ans 9 ans en
2011 neuf en sommes exactement donc
c'est normal qu'ils reprennent matin les
vols il fait un grand une grande fierté
pour le pays et surtout d'un signal de
leur leadership pour les activités
spatiales habitées
on va en parler évidemment après le
lancement il reste 3 minutes 47
exactement le remplissage des réservoirs
s'est effectuée à 20h37 alors que les
astronautes sont à bord c'est c'est nous
aurons sécurité c'est normal j'ai
produire normal pour ce type de fusée
ont fait le remplissage à partir du
moment où les as en son temps la fusée
parce que le temps de préparation et
d'installation des astronautes en la
fusée dans leur capsule est plus long
que celui qui est nécessaire pour le
remplissage des réservoirs donc l'objet
de fer avec les procédures là donc quel
état d'esprit est ce que l'on est là on
voit évidemment ces deux astronautes
douglas hurley et robert behnken qui
sont à bord des images en direct dans
quel état d'esprit et on quand on fait
ce type d'exploit alors imaginez vous
bien qu'ils ont été dans le simulateur
qui représente fidèlement ce qu'est le
crew dragons depuis plusieurs mois voire
même plusieurs années avant le décollage
tant qu'ils sont dans leur environnement
habituel ils sont ils sont pas dépaysés
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont en face
d'eux
ils sont prêts en plus si l'on connaît
il connaît très très bien les ingénieurs
donc il ya un climat de confiance qui
s'installe entre les astronautes les
ingénieurs donc ils sont très confiants
pour le décollage comme comme je le suis
également
et ils vont ensuite une fois que le
décollage ait fait le travail pour eux
va vraiment commencer parce que ya la
phase deux rendez vous qui va être assez
longue puisqu'elle va durer environ 17 à
18 heures puis après le rendez vous sur
la station proprement dit puis après
l'évolution du vaisseau symbole des
seize est très important parce qu'il
fonctionne en le réussissent pour
valider les des collages successifs
il n'y a pas de stress me le confirmer
il ya du stress il ya toujours du stress
il ya toujours un sentiment de peur
surtout sur un véhicule qui a été lancé
pour la première fois avec un équipage
mais il faut savoir que ce ce type de
véhicule 7,4 sua déjà et déjà parier
plus enfin dans l'espace de façon
automatique donc c'est pratiquement la
même qu'à dessus avec la même fusée qui
redécolle dans l'espace avec des
modifications nécessaires à
l'accommodation des astronautes à bord
de la capsule il reste une minute 43
exactement les conditions météo ont
failli reporter encore un soc au
lancement
oui c'était 50-50 tout à l'heure du
maintenant la envoie causé ciel bleu les
conditions météo sont très mauvaises moi
même lorsque je décollais en 99 sur la
mission sts 93 mon décollage a été
reporté trois fois pour des conditions
techniques et météo
donc on est habitués en floride avoir
des airs pan de l'écolage assez fréquent
que je sois en navette ou bien cette
fois-ci l'on décapsule parce que
évidemment ce qui prime c'est la
sécurité absolue des astronautes
absolument donc là tout et tout est prêt
pour le décollage est tout et nominales
pour l'instant si la météo est bonne
maintenant il faut vraiment que la
séquence de décollage soit bonne
également du vote technique et c'est
qu'il faut savoir que le le décollage
peut être arrêté quelques secondes avant
décollage bien sûr également à mon
premier première tentative de décollage
mon dégoût là j'ai été arrêtée à sept
secondes alors que l'allumage du moteur
se faisait à 6 secondes après le
décollage
oui donc tout peut s'arrêter quelques
secondes avant le concorde au décollage
on s'arrête d'un coup on est déçu alors
vision était su parce que on descend on
sait que ça va être reportée
et on sait pas si ça va vraiment trop
porté tant qu'à une grande ya une grande
phase d'incertitude face urnes et on est
inquiet et vous avez vu que les a sont
instables dans la capsule deux heures et
demie avant décollage et bien lorsqu on
ressort sur la navette il faut pas tout
attendre encore deux heures et demie
pour ressentir de la navette donc sa
photo d'alpha coeur mais quand vous
faites ça traite avec nous michel tonini
le décompte a commencé dix secondes
avant un lancement le compte à rebours
je vous laisse la vérité y regarde pas
sûr
car si bagdad
dans quatre ans
[Musique]
le monde est probant
y
m
[Musique]
comment
michel tonini donc on a suivi en direct
ces images d'un lancement réussi un
michel tonini quels sont les stades
précisément et les stades critiques
qu'elles sont les minutes où l'on
retient son souffle pour dire au final
que c'est réussi
alors pensez pas encore réussi tant que
la combustion de lancement de la fusée
n'a pas été terminé temps plein temps on
est toujours en propulsion où ils vont
attendre la propulsion il ya environ
neuf minutes de profession qu'il faut
attendre
vous avez eu que la fusée a décollé on
utilise une procédure qui est similaire
à celle de la navette spatiale c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on pages le q max et
l'association de la vitesse maximale
associé à la densité d'hyères maximale
on doit réduire les moteurs
c'est ce qu'ils ont annoncé ensuite les
différentes stages qui sont des stages
de sécurité de la cuisine c'est à dire
qu'à partir d'un certain moment qu'à une
panne on doit se poser en mer on doit se
poser un certain endroit
ce sont les stages qu'on a entendu un
bravo et cetera et donc ces stages ont
été passées et une séparation du premier
étage nous plaisir à plusieurs étages au
pointage ainsi la combustion est tombé
derrière la fusée derrière le deschaux
élevé si on continue avec son 2e étage
plus le besco dragonne en hauteur donc
on voit toujours la combustion se
déroule djiar et il faudra attendre la
fin de la combustion donc environ neuf
minutes à combler tout à l'heure pour
être sûr que c'est le décollage
il y aurait ici complètement
complètement essai c'est la phase
dynamique et la plus importante bien sûr
elle est courte mais la plus importante
parce que tout peut dériver très
rapidement bien sûr sur le roulis et le
tangage de la c est ça peut être grave
et donc au delà de ces neuf minutes on
peut dire que ce lancement est réussi à
kehl à quelle vitesse cette fusée
précisément alors la vitesse d'orbitz et
28 kilomètres à l'heure dans quel est en
accélération constante à environ 3,3 g
et lg environ en moyenne pour arriver à
une vitesse de 28 km à l'heure en
l'espace de neuf minutes c'est un profil
qui est similaire au décollage de la
fusée soyouz ou de la fusée spatiale ou
même de la fusée chinoise qui envoie les
les dessous dans l'espace alors vous
parlez de la fusée soyouz maintenant
c'est une fusée
privée américaine qui sera en mesure
d'acheminer les spationautes vers la
station internationale
c'est un ce qu'est ce que ça va changer
c'est une nouvelle ère ce vraiment dans
la conquête spatiale
ça veut dire que la nasa a dit qu' elle
voulait laisser ses vols en orbite basse
coco sociétés commerciales en disant que
mes volant dans une basse ont été
réalisés par nasa depuis de nombreuses
années avec succès donc un adverbe
libérer du budget en laissant l'accès la
rue de basse ou longtemps presse privée
et en s'autorisant la nasa à faire les
missions qui sont plus complexes en
mission pour aller sur la lune ou sur
mars ou sur les greens
donc c'est une répartition qui montre
clairement la volonté de la nasa de se
faire de l'exploration spatiale en
dehors de leur big bag de l'ordre de
passe et données sordide basse ou
sautaient commercial ce qui fait aussi
gagner de l'argent à la nasa mais qui
donne aussi un budget conséquent à la
société space x et ce n'était pas gagné
puisqu'il a fallu avoir l'approbation du
congrès et de l'asin c'est une société
privée du milliardaire lots de masques
on le rappelle le combat était pas gagné
le combat de nine mais comme à vivre
savoir que deux puits 2012 space x a
fait de nombreux décollage quand est
réussie dans la tête enfin gea tout
ravitaillement
du côté américain de la présentation a
été faite par des véhicules lancés par
aux caciques et on au fur à mesure de
ses lancements aussi rendu compte que ça
fonctionnait bien donc la confiance
s'est bien installée entre la nasa et il
en offre pour les décollages et pour ce
décollage aussi donc c'est c'était pas
gagné peut-être mais quand même les
chances étaient balle très bonne de
réussir il était tout à fait l'intérêt
de la nasa d'avoir un retour à
l'acquisition d'envoi des hommes dans
l'espace pour avoir leur autonomie sur
l'autonomie par l'espace puisqu'il était
dépendant des russes depuis 2011 et vous
nous confirmer c'est la fusée la plus
puissante au monde
à ce stade il reste quelques secondes
pour passer ce seuil critique des idées
neuf minutes vous ne confirmerai bien
sûr oui alors c'est pas la fusée la plus
puissante au monde est monde ce que la
fusée saturn 5 qui n'en sait qu'ils
n'étaient 100 tonnes qui
pour arriver sur la lune dont c'était
très puissant cette fusée la falcon 9
qui est plus faible mais ils ont une
version différente que la falcon tall
sall qui est un ensemble de trois fusées
à closer qui seront mises autour les qui
aurait le puissant ce encore plus forte
et là donc on peut dire que le lancement
est réussi il est 21h 30 nous allons
prendre l'antenne un michel tonini pour
vous c'est un succès moi c'est un grand
succès jusqu'à présent puisque
pratiquement terminée donc même s'il y
avait une panne à ce niveau là on
pourrait partir sur une orbite plus
basse mais pour moi il est réussi et
puis avoir une séparation est la mission
de la propulsion été réussi maintenant
il reste à faire le rendez vous est le
rendez vous mais pas à si rappelez-vous
que la mission équivalente par l'autre
société qui est bring a réussi à tenter
d'offrir une mission réussie l'année
dernière ils ont pas réussi parce que
ils n'ont pas pu faire le rendez vous
sur la station donc aujourd'hui la
première phase a été a été réussi
maintenant la deuxième phase que le
rendez vous qui êtes à réussir aussi y
la troisième chose qui est aussi la
berbie tation la rentrée dans
l'atmosphère et d'atterrissage d'un
dressage
donc ça c'est on n'aura pas le bilan
complet de cette mission tant que
l'atterrissage n'a pas été fait de façon
complète et en sécurité
merci beaucoup michel tonini on va
suivre évidemment toutes ces évolutions
merci beaucoup pour votre expertise pour
ce premier lancement d'une fusée privée
vers la station spatiale internationale
c'est là